this is what knowledge is
we want truth
yes we want there to be some
correspondence between what is in our
minds and what the world is like but you
can have truth without knowledge
how is that
because for aristotle to know something
is true
is to know the causes for the thing
aristotle distinguishes four different
kinds of causes the material cause the
formal cause the efficient cause and the
final cause i'm going to go through each
one of those they're very important to
know and i'll try and illustrate with
this apple
the material cause first
that's obvious
to most of you there's matter that makes
up this apple it's the sort of thing you
could study in chemistry for example the
sort of chemical makeup uh of this apple
and there are some views uh in the
modern world that the matter is all
there is that material causes or
physical causes can explain
all of reality
but here's a thought experiment take
this apple
and
press it down
grind it down until it's just pulp
and then
ask yourself the question
is that still an apple
all of the matter
is still there
but something has changed
what
aristotle
says that's the formal cause
all of nature is comprised of a
combination of material and formal
causes it's the form that makes things
what they are
aristotle uses a technical term for this
he calls it hylomorphism
the greek word hila means matter morphe
means form everything is composed of
matter and form and it's the form that
ultimately explains the reality we see
around us
i mentioned two of the causes there's a
third
what caused this apple to be
it didn't just pop into existence out of
nowhere
it came from a tree
and the tree
developed and matured and made fruit and
inside the fruit are the seeds of the
apple and then the apple fell from the
tree so the efficient cause for
aristotle is what begins the motion
which originates which brings that apple
into its existence
now we have to get to the
uh the final cause of the apple and that
is notice this about this apple
this apple
if it falls to the ground
and becomes properly embedded within the
soil and receives enough rain
will start to grow
into another apple tree
it has therefore what aristotle calls
the potency
it has the potency in it to become
something more mature more developed it
is then
and this is aristotle's great innovation
what is an apple
aristotle will tell us an apple is an
immature
apple tree
this is an apple tree
at a very high degree of potency and a
low degree of actuality when this apple
grows into a full apple tree it is the
most what an apple is its potency has
been actualized
as aristotle understands it
those causes go back
eternally
the world eternally goes back
in efficient causes
but aristotle doesn't think
that
we could have that world without some
kind of ultimate
causal explanation
and aristotle doesn't think
it can be an efficient cause at the
beginning of time because he thinks
those causes can't go back eternally
so he explains it in terms of a final
cause
aristotle looks at all the changes or
motions in the cosmos and he notices an
order among them
beginning with the sublunar causes in
our world and then looking at the
motions of the heavens he sees them as
causing the things below them
he suggests that for all of that
infinite series of causation there must
be some kind of cause which is not an
efficient cause but which is a final
cause and it is itself not caused by
anything else otherwise you need an
explanation for that cause
he calls this cause the prime mover or
the unmoved mover and he spends
extensive time explaining and defending
and arguing for
the fact that we need to have a prime
mover to make sense of causality
how could the unmover cause the movement
of everything else
think about how
the apple and the tree might move you
the apple just sits in the tree
it doesn't push you
it draws you
you see the apple and you think that
looks good
for food it looks juicy i will not add
and to make me intelligent like the gods
uh we're not talking about the story the
fall here we see an apple and it
attracts our will and we go after it the
apple
serves in itself
as a final cause for the movement of our
will towards the apple and so aristotle
beautifully
tells us and suggestively tells us the
the highest cause the prime mover moves
all the rest of the cosmos by eliciting
love
but it in itself is a self-thinking
thought it does not oversee or manage
the cosmos it exists for itself like the
apple exists for itself in the tree but
it attracts all the rest of us toward
itself that is a source of
intelligibility in the cosmos
[Music]
you